a few weeks ago we introduced the
character on our show named Mick
Ferguson the man who's awfully proud of
his bulletproof legs and if you didn't
get to see his appearance take a look at
what happened oh you can't hurt me
because I have bulletproof legs oh they
cost me a fortune but Joe
now Mick has appeared twice since that
unfortunate evening and sadly both times
the results were exactly the same well
folks there has been a miracle on the
bright side Mick has made a full
recovery and he's willing to give his
song and dance routine another try
so please welcome back for the fourth
time Mick Ferguson the man who's ugly
proud of his bulletproof legs oh I've
got bulletproof legs I've got
bulletproof legs oh you can't hurt me
cuz I the bulletproof legs oh they cost
me a fortune buncha don' : what the hell
why is this guy here man he's always
here I don't know yeah of course you
don't know you never know but the fact
is he's always here and he always shoots
me the last three times cone and he shot
me in the heart
have you ever been shot in the heart
Conan no Mick I have never been shot in
the heart do you think it feels good I
don't know oh you don't know well let me
tell you something about being shot in
the heart it hurts like hell it's kind
of an important organ you know the
circulatory system right now it makes
the blood go around at night yeah okay
my question is what do you want me to do
about it I mean what am I supposed to do
well every time I come out here you know
you're like no he doesn't have a gun
trust me
tonight I want you to make him show me
the gun that I know he has all right now
sir if you wouldn't mind could we see
your gun hey all right
okay now that we know you have it please
for the sake of everything holy shoot my
legs tonight not my heart my legs they
cost me a fortune they're bulletproof
and I want to find out if they work okay
so I sing and you shoot my legs here we
go all I've got bulletproof legs I got
bulletproof legs oh yeah they work
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're gonna take a little break
right now clean up the mess when we come
back Vickie Lewis is gonna be here so
stick